So the answer to this question is that it's the
X chromosome. And it's likely to be recessive. Now, how do
we come up with that? Well, we're pretty sure that
it can't be the Y chromosome. Think about it. Take this
father as an example. This father up here is affected,
that means he'd have a Y chromosome with the affected allele.
He had two daughters. Did he give his Y chromosome
to a daughter? No, there's no way, right? Because they're daughters.
Daughters are by definition XX. So if this daughter
is XX, she didn't get any affected Y from the
father. So how did she pass on the trait to
her son? Right, that just doesn't make sense. It must
be the X. Here the X is affected. And
the father passes that X on to this daughter. But
because this daughter has another X from the mother that's
unaffected, you don't see the trait. She's just a carrier.
But when she has a son, the son is XY, the son has to get the X from
the mother, she gave him the recessive allele X.
And we also suspect that this trait, this allele
causing this trait is recessive. Because as we mentioned
before in our autosomal inheritance pattern pedigrees. Recessive traits
tend to skip generations, and unaffected parents have affected
offspring. Whereas dominant traits show up in every generation.
Or almost every generation, and many times affected parents have
affected offspring, and that's not the case for this pedigree.